we are taking calls at 607 830 4750 we
are going to take our next call from the
785 area code I have embracing for
something by taking this call caller
what's your name and where you're
calling from hi my name is Kayla and I'm
from Lawrence Kansas oh okay I you you
have the same area code as who the
person we know as the Kansas troll which
is a very very antagonistic person but I
can tell from your voice that you're not
that even though you share the area code
well what's on your mind I was wondering
does America have a representative
democracy if a minority of the
population folks and a minority of the
people who did vote ended up selecting
someone okay so many people chose not to
vote so when you ask them whether they
feel like they participated many of them
would say well I participated by
exercising my right not to vote but what
you're getting at is something that that
I think is asked a different way
analyzed in detail there's a Princeton
study which says we're not really a
democracy we're really an oligarchy
because you're sort of pointing out
voter turnout information in the reality
that twenty-six percent of the country
actually voted for the person that is
president and in addition even among the
people that voted nearly three million
more voted for Hillary Clinton than than
for Donald Trump but there's a very
aspect of this which i think is
completely insidious and it goes beyond
voter turnout which is if you are a rich
person I'm not sure if you're taking
note on this so that I I'm honored that
you may be taking notes on this if
you're a rich person or a corporation
your legislative and policy desires are
way more likely to be taken seriously
and pursued as law by our lawmakers and
if you're just kind of like an average
person who is in poverty or earns a sort
of average income and that is something
that to me a voter turnout the problem
and the fact that so many people chose
not to vote I don't like that and I
think we should work on that but the
fact that by virtue of having
money it's way more likely that what you
want to happen legislatively will happen
that Oleg our Google reality that's
going on is something that I think we
need to be really really concerned about
and the current administration is only
going to make that worse so can I ask a
follow-up question to that yes
absolutely so does that mean if if you
are rich that voting is more important
to you because of the system that we
have now it's more representative of
rich people well the interesting thing
is if you have a lot of money you don't
actually need to vote because it's the
money itself that will actually give you
the political capital so it's an
interesting way to follow up on the
question but I think it's actually quite
the opposite which is because of the
system we have voting is not actually
the best way as a rich person to achieve
change at this point it's using your
money to buy influence and achieve
change something by the way the
president brags about doing when he was
a private citizen thanks so much for the
call always great to hear from Kansas
and hope to hear from you again